[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du cetud culture
on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
édition spéciale sur le festival bd de
l'avis de l'udc
on va aller à la rencontre d'auteurs de
dessinateurs ou encore de passionnés moi
je m'équipe et qui on va aller à leur
rencontre yves et moi pouvait
m
mais je me trouve en compagnie de john
coleman et maire-adjoint délégué à la
communication et à la démocratie
constructive de la vie de biberons soir
bonsoir je signe
suis heureux de vous accueillir ce soir
pour ce festival quand ce 27e festival
de la bande dessinée
si vous permettez je vais enlever le
masque vu qu'on a suffisamment de
silence entre nous est ce que pouvaient
déjà nous présenter le festival
oui le festival aujourd'hui c'est le 27e
festival c'est un festival qui est de
plus en plus connu et qui rassemble
cette année ci de façon exceptionnelle
va rassemble 25 auteurs comparativement
aux années précédentes où nous avions eu
cinquante auteurs
c'était ici en raison de la crise nous
avons des deux auteurs qui vient
essentiellement d'europe d'ekali de
belgique
et de france bien évidemment il y aura
également moins de visiteurs cette année
l'année dernière nous avions fait 8000
entrées c'était ni si nous tablons sur
2500 à 3000 d'entrée sur le week-end il
était important de maintenir
d'où notre volonté de travailler avec
les services de la préfecture que le
protocole que vous voyez qui a été mise
en place pour sécuriser la présence des
visiteurs dans le cadre de cette crise
sanitaire
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver sur
place vous avez des artistes dans tous
les domaines des bd de science fiction
des bd pour adultes des bd pour enfants
est ce qui fait la popularité de ce
festival des ateliers réalisés en amont
du festival
le but c'était quoi c'était de rendre la
culture en tout cas le neuvième art
accessible à tous absolument c'était de
rendre la culture accessible à tous et
aussi de permettre de mieux connaître le
festival à travers quatre autres mini
festival dans les différentes communes
avoisinant les créations qui ont été
faites pendant cette estivale si j'ai
bien compris son exposé sur le week end
est-il absolument absolument les toutes
les créations sont exposées depuis
vendredi soir et jusqu'à demain soir
est-ce que vous avez un coup de coeur
sur un auteur qui est présent ce
week-end alors j'ai trois auteurs que
que j'hérite évidemment johan que j'ai
eu l'honneur de rencontrer ce matin j'ai
bien aimé capezzone pezzi parce que ça
m'a rappelé une bd de mon enfance et
également du llano bertino nick est
arrivé d'italie façon exceptionnelle
cette année c'est l'année de la bd est
ce que pour vous le savez aussi encore
plus en valeur le festival oui tout à
fait vous l'avez peut-être remarqué que
les villes autour de nous notamment
versailles et les quatre autres
festivals que je vous ai mentionné tout
à l'heure l'objectif de tout cela c'est
évidemment de mettre la bd à l'honneur
vous l'avez dit c'est un festival qui
accueille en tout cas qui accueille et
les éditions précédentes ce sont la
colline près de 8000 personnes
c'est un événement est devenu
indispensable dans un événement qui est
de plus en plus connu en tout cas et
il devient j'ose dire un comprendra
brille tout à fait merci d'avoir été
avec mon revers de 1500 personnes on
vous l'a dit était attendu pendant les
deux jours du festival
nous avons fait la rencontre de
plusieurs passionnés notamment de jean
luc qui adore la bande dessinée les
venues pour la 27e fois rencontré ses
auteurs favoris regard des 27 c'est le
nombre de fois que jean luc a participé
au festival bd de buc passionné il n'a
loupé aucune édition et possède des
milliers de bandes dessinées le but quoi
nous explique son penchant pour le
neuvième art il ya des scénaristes de
bande dessinée qui nous font
qui nous transporte et ajoutez à cela
des saints qui peut être
génial génial
alors franchement que demander de plus
alors faire mètres linéaires de tranches
beaucoup beaucoup
en fait non
amédée l'événement était l'occasion de
se faire et dédicacé plusieurs bd
parmi elles elle n'a comme une histoire
en deux tomes
elle retrace les aventures de gonzalo
guerrero le conquistador devenue
générale maya ça franchement je vous
conseille l'achat de cet album c'est une
histoire vraie on peut dire
c'est une histoire vraie c'est une
histoire en deux tomes sur les mayas je
me suis fait dédicacer vos doigts de
ville
sur l'ouvragé bruxelles 43 le nouvel
alix de monsieur albert fini de se
coller passionnés de bd jean luc attend
déjà avec impatience l'édition 2021
alors vous l'avez compris à cette 27ème
édition du festival de bd de but
c'est le rendez vous avait pas sur les
deux bandes dessinées et nous en avons
rencontré certains durant les séances de
dédicaces regard des 2500 c'est le
nombre de visiteurs qui étaient attendus
pendant le week-end du festival bd à buc
des passionnés venus rencontrer leurs
auteurs favoris et profiter des séances
de dédicaces la junte en avant des gaz
de monsieur olivier pâques
voilà sur le voyage de l'oit versailles
de louis xiii
il fait partie de mes auteurs préférés
je parle avec olivier martin qui est en
train de faire une dédicace son album
s'appelle j'ai tué ma rares et que j'ai
adoré et donc du coup on est train de
discuter un petit peu de comment il
avait conçu l'album etc
et puis j'attends qu'ils finissent le
dessin et c'est ça qui est plutôt
intéressant dans un salon de bande
dessinée c'est vraiment rencontrer des
auteurs qui nous ont fait rêver en
lisant des albums et parmi les auteurs
présents sur place et thierry capezzone
et le dessinateur de p2i car si le p tit
rafle le dernier album le cochon volant
qu'on a fait aux éditions aux éditions
correct et si c'est magique c'est une bd
ou ou petty la construire un avion et
c'est un avion tu sais qu'on avait dans
le temps en avion avec un élastique de
l'eau je suis venu dédicacer mes albums
de pepsi pezi c'est un personnage danois
de 1951 qui va fêter ses soixante dix
ans allait prochaine et donc je fais ça
moi j'ai repris la série depuis 2011
au total 25 auteurs étaient présents
lors de l'événement
[Musique]
nous sommes en compagnie de johan lionel
bon soir bonjour vous êtes auteur de bd
et notamment des aventures de spirou et
fantasio
je suis un dessinateur anvers bien les
dessinateurs en date depuis 2
2010une a repris la série classique des
grands scénaristes et vous avez aussi
réalisé l'affiché du festival avec deux
buts
j'ai eu l'immense honneur d'organiser la
fiche du festival cette année
est ce qu'on peut nous parler un peu de
votre parcours en tant qu'auteur j'ai
commencé en faisant de la bande dessinée
jeunesse et de christian delcourt
j'écris que ça peut tantôt
l'ornithorynque
d'animaux
les animaux australiens puis par la cedh
et travailler avec jeremstar et lewiston
m sur deux ans
je fais partie des auteurs
son poisson pilote
c'est dargaud et puis de fil en aiguille
j'ai rencontré fabien vehlmann qui
travaillent et qui sans doute lui
à qui on a proposé à l'époque de
reprendre la série spirou et fantasio en
tant que scénariste et
il est parti en quête de dessinateur il
a pensé à moi et
ou les deux quant à manu s'en trouverait
santé yeh belle aventure j'ai peur
arrangements rock dansant comment on
trouve l'inspiration quand on est auteur
de bd comme vous en général c'est rare
quand on vient voilà scénario en général
avec la scénariste nous farcir des idées
tient ce serait drôle si on faisait ça
si on mettait de personnel dentelle de
conditions
vivre cette aventure et
c'est beaucoup plus fun que de ruminer
les choses tout seul ce que l'opération
ait pas facilement
c'est un peu l'union fait la force vous
avez accepté le festival de but que
c'est une longue histoire en fait ça
fait d'être quasiment une dizaine
d'années qu'il est fier d'inviter tous
les ans et à chaque fois je refusais
parce que il tombe au moment de mon
anniversaire alors généralement
anniversaire je préfère le passé en
famille mais là ce truc que cette année
ils étaient un petit peu décalé visage
mon anniversaire donc j'ai pu me libérer
pour venir en plus un festival où les
auteurs invités sont la plupart du temps
c'est des copains sont des gens que je
connais le milieu de la bande dessinée
est un petit milieu et on est content de
se retrouver ensemble et d'autant plus
en cette période un petit peu compliqué
on a été confinée pendant des mois chez
nous on est content de retrouver les
copains la guerre en avance merci
beaucoup c'est une petite démonstration
de dessin j'ai toujours pas de problème
on va prendre dix minutes pas ça
qu'est ce
[Musique]
[Rires]
wayne cole est votre rôle au sein du
festival est ce que vous êtes là plutôt
pour conseiller des dessinateurs en mer
pour faire les dédicaces pour rencontrer
les gens ce festival en particulier
c'est plutôt un festival de dédicaces où
je rencontre mes lecteurs donc l'intérêt
pour moi c'est d'avoir des retours sur
mes albums de voir comment ils ont
ressenti les dernières nouveautés et
puis ils répondent à leurs questions
aussi quant à la suite mais quand le
prochain album quels sont les projets
tout ça donc c'est un peu ça alors l'est
avec fabien vehlmann donc le scénariste
de spirou on a démarré une nouvelle
série dérivée de spirou qui s'appelle
super groupe et on a imaginé qu'à un
moment donné de ses aventures spirou
utiliser les inventions du comte de
champignac qui est un savant peut se
créer un personnage de super héros à la
base c'est pour faire de la publicité au
journal de spirou qui va perdre le
contrôle de la situation et se retrouve
être véritablement un super héros merci
à mon équipe le monde de la bande
dessinée mais on reste dans la culture
avec le prisme qui a rouvert ses portes
qui a présenté la saison culturelle 2020
2021 à elancourt ça s'est déroulé le
mercredi 7 octobre d'événements été
l'occasion de présenter les nombreux
spectacles à venir
au programme théâtre danse musique
patrick jacques de dixmude s'est rendue
à la soirée
le prisme a ouvert sa saison culturelle
2020 2021
l'événement a lieu mercredi 7 octobre à
elancourt une soirée importante pour
l'établissement qui compte sur le
soutien du public c'est celle où à la
fois on montre tout le travail que l'on
a préparé dont on espère qu'il sera une
réussite pour cette nouvelle saison mais
c'est également celle où bien entendu
nous comptons sur la fidélité de nos
spectateurs et nous espérons faire un
maximum d'abonnement ce soir c'est une
programmation pluridisciplinaire qui
attend les spectateurs des thèmes autour
de l'humour du plaisir ou encore de la
réflexion toujours de l'écriture et de
la création contemporaine avec le
calibre théâtre création chorégraphique
la compagnie mémé banjo qui viendra
également créé ici cette saison un
spectacle qui s'appelle dimanche
éperdument programmateur et artistes
étaient au rendez vous pour présenter la
saison à venir
ils nous parlent de leur spectacle
chacun dans un style différent
vraiment on demande en direct aux gens
de nous donner des thèmes donc ça peut
arriver que ce soit le coc vide ou
d'autres choses ou leur vie privée par
exemple la dernière fois c'est un mec
qui avait il perdait ses cheveux
donc il voulait qu'on parle de sa perte
de cheveux et on on a parlé de ça juste
vous demander pour faire connaissance
regardez la personne qui est assis à
votre droite regardez la personne cas
c'est le droit de regarder bien cette
personne au jeu vous demander en toute
bienveillance et en toute honnêteté
évidemment de me donner une note de 1 à
10 sur la physique de sur le physique de
cette personne moi je fais un théâtre
qui est assez particulier qui mélange
habituellement
du théâtre récit de la danse hip hop de
l'image animée et de la musique live
la saison du prisme débutera avec un
spectacle de marc lavoine le samedi 9
janvier 2021
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission spéciale
festival bd de l'udc
merci de nous avoir suivis moi j'ai eu
mon petit chapeau de spirou et nous on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une nouvelle émission 7,8 culture en
direct bonne soirée à tous surtout les
[Musique]